Ah, Patty, you said a few weeks ago that MMS is toxic.
What are the scientists, Dr. Proponents of MMS, who state emphatically that it is not
toxic, missing?
What are they missing?
Well, well, first of all, everything is toxic at a certain dose.
I mean, vitamin C is going to be toxic at a certain dose.
Everything is going to be toxic and water is toxic at a certain dose.
So you can't say something is not toxic.
Certainly, MMS is, I don't know, any good scientist who would say that it's not toxic.
If it was truly a scientist, they would say, everything is toxic at a certain dose.
But I don't think that it's toxic at most doses that are recommended.
Where I struggle with MMS is the high doses that are recommended for cancer treatments, because
those are very high doses of MMS.
So anything that you're taking can, that is, for the purpose of killing bacteria, we used
to use MMS, I've said this before, a lot with, when we see a lot more line patients, I used
to put good percentage of line patients on MMS, it was great results with that.
So it is, I think it's a great antibacterium, but we used to see issues with people's
microbiota.
So we, it's similar, but not as potent as an antibiotic, so you'd have to scale that back.
You'd have to ram people up very slowly with MMS too, or they would feel sick.
So you could see symptoms if people, oh, did, on MMS, even still well within the non-toxic
quote unquote dosage.
So you just have to be careful with it, like you're careful with anything else.
So I am nothing against somebody using MMS, but just like anything else, you have to be careful.
For instance, you know, we get questions about fat menisol, and using fat menisol, I think
fat menisol is a great thing for cancer.
But you have to keep an eye, I ask people that are on fat menisol, could you please get
a complete metabolic pedal on a very regular basis, because I have seen many times people
on fat menisol, it spikes their ALT, AST, et alkyl and phosphatase.
Those are signs of liver toxicity, so you've got to keep an eye on that.
So anything, I think fat menisol is a good drug to kill cancer, but you have to be careful
of its toxicity.
And understand, these people are taking fat menisol at a dosage that is given to a 10 pound
dog.
So it's far below the human dosage use of menbendizol.
So it's anything can be toxic, even at far below its LD, what's called a lethal dose, far
below it can be toxic to any given human being, depending on how that human being metabolizes
it.
So anything can be toxic to me based on how I am able to metabolize that and how I am
able to detoxify it.
So whatever you're taking, something that has a greater chance of that, I suggest you
stay on top of looking at your complete metabolic panel and do a CBC at the same time so that
you're making sure that you're not toxified your liver, because you can end up with liver
failure.
I mean, understand, statistically, there's over 15,000 people a year in the United States
that die from Tylenol, DOST, adequately according to label, why is that?
Because it's 80 drug can be toxic, anything can be toxic.
So typically, yes, typically, those are people with other cold morbidities, absolutely, they're
not just a normal person like, oh, I'm going to take a Tylenol for a headache and I haven't
taken it for six months, typically they're people that are ill with other cold morbidities.
Typically, you know, could also say that those people are taking Tylenol every day and they're
using it every day for their headaches, that they have every day because they're not
dealing with underlining problems.
There's probably a lot of people in that category, but, you know, a person that's taken, then
is off of their cancer, they're taking it every day and a person that's taking MMS for
their cancer, they're taking it every day, just keep an eye on your liver markers, that's
all I'm saying.
Just keep an eye on that, keep an eye on symptoms, pain, like I'm getting this weird pain or
my liver gallbladder area that I don't usually get, that's very common when you have liver
toxicity.
So, if you don't have time to go get your complete metabolic panel, pain over the liver area
can be an early indicator of that, maybe just go to pulse these things.
So whenever I see that with the person that's been medisol, I'm taking them off with a
medisol.
You're off for a month until we get these numbers back in order and I've had some people
like, I really want to get back on this, I really think this is helping me.
Okay, but you're going to die of liver failure.
So we've got to go off for a period of time and tell these numbers come back to normal and
then they can go back on it again.
So, but you've got to keep an eye on that, that's all you've got to do, just be careful.